what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch the second episode
of wanda vision super excited to check
this
out as per usual make sure to subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
notified when our next one division
reaction is up and if you enjoy this
please go ahead and hit that like button
also pretty useful length reaction watch
as long as we stick up with the time
coder all over
our patreon page this qualifies as
reaction highlights over at our patreon
we cover a whole bunch of shows with
watch-alongs and reaction highlights
it's it's a bottle of a time it's a gas
[Laughter]
lastly gotta thank our buddy eric over
at nerd chronic for editing these
reaction highlights for us
trust me after editing cobra kai know
how much work goes into these so thank
you so much dude
for doing this my friend you rocky edits
for people like movie trivia shmo down
iman snow
a whole bunch of people too much your
name right now eric is a good guy please
give him a follow on twitter
let's let's let's watch this time with
that transition
[Music]
i even got like oh that's great
classic lighting hue there are you using
your night vision vision
oh sure i love i see nothing in this you
have absolutely no reason
that's not allowed in this time
and look how you seized on the
opportunity to redecorate
this is better
[Music]
rated x no way
yes yes
[Music]
brilliant oh whoever got hired to do
this
must have had such a ball
what are they changing credits every
episode i wouldn't be surprised
i want popcorn as i illusion master of
enigma
make my captivating assistant glamour
disappear
you really are very dashing thank you
darling
ah this is some magic is revealed might
just see through this
little charade well that's the whole
point this whole thing's a charade
i want us to fit in oh
darling we do especially with you
wearing this that's actually the rest of
your costume
try it on
2800. remember that what issue of comics
earth 2800
[Laughter]
oh crap
he's gonna be like get this color out of
my neighborhood that's gonna completely
be misinterpreted
the era man that inadvertently sparks
the civil rights movement
oh morning dennis stick him up
[Laughter]
yeah so you have an affair with the
mailman just mind your p's and cues and
you're gonna do
just fine or maybe i could just be
myself
oh wanda that's good
i'm sorry daddy i didn't ask about the
chairs
so you better not ask me if you can
chair any committees in the future
oh the devil's in the details bev
that's not the only place he is as you
all know
the devil memphis oh before he's coming
[Music]
so i want you all to give yourselves a
big hand
[Applause]
i'm wanda i'm uh
geraldine hi and i'm irritated is that
your real name
is that your real name
oh remember the public library
yeah used to rent dvds that's the place
i envisioned didn't expect to see you
here
could you tell me how often you wrote a
security patrol student faced directly
with local law enforcement
raspberry or cheese filled oh
neither for me thank you i don't eat
food
[Laughter]
what i mean to say is that i don't eat
food in between meals but a meal
times woof of a regular eating machine
now you know how johnson's been bragging
about that tree house he built for his
kid
yeah it's a pre-fab job
norm here's a communist oh no
told you that mustache you know i always
thought you're kind of a square
me no i'm as round as they come
[Laughter]
careful stick a big red is gum food well
my understanding is that it's purely for
um mastication when in west view cheers
remember when we first learned that word
in biology
we actually thought you were serious
oh no ah
i've heard things about you but i assure
you i don't mean anyone
any harm they know they're a polyamorous
couple
swinging 60s man
cool cool wow
how does a housewife get a blood stain
out of white linen
club soda by doing it herself
[Music]
no i don't want to break away from this
world i know
this one is struck her ah
struck her struck her he'll make
time hydra
so those characters in the commercials
must be stuck in this reality too
it's desert evolving oh no
[Music]
oh
wow what is going on you are
hello good afternoon
[Laughter]
i am glamour and he's illusion
you will believe our little deceptions
because human beings are easily
fooled due to their limited
understanding the inner workings of the
universe
check me out
[Music]
[Applause]
shhh
allow me
whoops you weren't supposed to see how
we did that prank
that was my grandmother's piano
stand up shervin sell on the crafts it's
herbert
oh it is pardon me herb have
well then i will just have to pull this
hat out of myself
[Music]
too far if only you all knew our secret
[Music]
are you sure you don't want an audience
volunteer named my husband
ralph oh gosh
what's in the box what's in the box
okay
[Applause]
what just happened to me not freaking
out
oh wow
that really gummed up my works didn't it
very good i know it's funny without it
yourself and that's all i care
[Applause]
how about anyone follow that act i know
we are so hilarious
you all agree
i've got a total
killing it
i like that guy how'd you do it oh a
magician never reveals his secrets he
leads up to his assistant
and she's not talking i had a feeling
you'd say that
they kidnap people all the time for the
children
for the children or wonder
hmm what oh
ever since you moved those beds together
if it's that damn tree again i am going
to
rip it out by the
spooky oh spooky
oh he looks so scared huh
cool
whoa oh is this really happening oh
damn
it's really happening you gotta let her
have her kids
oh
[Music]
this is like pleasantville
awesome awesome
awesome oh it's becoming the 70s
that's so cool
who's doing the sea wander wanda
that was so fun
and then then some full disclosure
we happened to get some screeners for
wanda vision
like as you saw there's a lot of people
who put out the review for the first
three episodes
and we got those screeners um today
today which is the day before the first
two episodes released so we have access
to the third episode that
so we're gonna record that right after
this and i don't know
if because sometimes marvel does this
with screenings and stuff back in the
day
if there's like a post-credits scene
that we did not
get access to because sometimes that
happens just letting you know if it's
not in here
that's why first off the geraldine
character
that's monica rambo right i believe it
is i'm not familiar with the actress but
uh from watching the trailers before and
be like oh that's monica
and learning that information i'm pretty
sure that's her she even had a moment of
hesitation when she's like uh
geraldine so i'm assuming monica rambo
was also trapped in here so it looks
like what juan has done and she's
created some type of alternate reality
and she hasn't like warped all of
reality she's created some little
hub or socket yeah this little pocket
that you know be like
i imagine sword is trying to find their
way to get into it
but she wants this to remain she wants
it to stay this way you know she has a
happy life here she has vision
like that threat coming out of there as
this like ominous
evil presence and her perspective are
probably not
bad guys at least that's what i'm
assuming it looks like we have those
people in the commercials it looks like
we got
you know monica rambo trapped here you
got agatha who's also
trapped here because i thought at first
you know from watching commercials that
maybe it was agatha is part of this or
helping to make this but it looks like
there's a lot of people who are just
kind of trapped in her reality and
perhaps some of these people just aren't
real or maybe there are a good chunk
maybe all these people are real
you know some kind of guys or some kind
of hypnosis or something
that's what i'm curious to find out
absolutely i guarantee you one is going
to bring back petra at some point oh
yeah that'd be good
that's cool they just got roommate
quicksilver at some point yeah she
should bring back both of them so that
we can get evan peters
cool cool yeah all right marvel talk out
of the way that's a hilarious episode
and i really really love the way like
it's it's subtle because both the first
episode and the second episode are
mostly in black and white but i love
that they went from the 50s
to the 60s the animated intro the
slightly different
shooting style the slightly different
production of the sets and whatnot
the production designs are so wonderful
and i love that they're really
authentically recreating these film
styles
yeah i mean even breaking away a little
bit more from the studio audience stuff
like how those 60s shows started to do
you're actually shooting on location in
certain areas
and then you would screen that for a
studio audience i mean i
i remember hearing that they shot the
first episode for a studio audience i
don't know if they did that here because
there are scenes that lend themselves to
it but even at the scenes
in home they have a lot more close-up
shots and over-the-shoulder shots versus
more cinematic yeah exactly but i
thought it was great you know getting to
know the neighborhood more
i get pulled into the actual like yeah
i get pulled into like the little stuff
i can pull the two i want this magic
show to go well
oh no they're revealing the magic hater
like i just wanted people to cover all
these things
like such a fun clever yeah it's so fun
and
getting to use these opportunities for i
just can't imagine
how happy both paul bettany and
elizabeth olsen were to be able to do
this show especially paul benny who
clearly has a wicked sense of humor oh
she had just doesn't get the opportunity
to truly showcase that in the mcu and
now he just gets to go all out
and using the gum effect to allow him to
portray
drunk character you know watch him play
drunk was hilarious
all the performers here everyone like
this this everyone in the town they're
all so damn good
yeah like i love the scene where they
have the little neighborhood watch
meeting and you're learning all these
guys who yeah like you're on the outside
with vision and then slowly over the
course of the scene like they're all
kind of plucky
characters but you do endear to them and
like herbert i actually got a big kick
out of as like their
weird little relationship kept
persisting
from the library meetup to the magic
show and the whole thing with the pick a
card
i'm wondering with the wives club
especially with the head of their the
queen bee
she's got that role like locked that
actress she's great yeah that's
great and i'm starting to like question
is she
a bigger character than we realize yeah
she's
letting on to something or whatever she
placating them or
trying to get some other marvel
characters yeah
is she emma frost she looked like her
yeah yeah i mean
anytime you got like a platinum blonde
that way yeah yeah
and in that commercial though they did
have
the the moment with the watch where you
see the hydra symbol and there's a
strucker on it
now struck her remembering correctly you
see him
at the end of cap the post-credits scene
captain america winter soldier when
they're experimenting with the scepter
that's the first time you see wanda and
pietro
you know so he's like i think he's the
main person responsible for
giving them the powers within the mcu i
think he's the main person responsible
for that experimentation
yeah oh damn they were going back
back to the beginning of that meeting
everything is important
i was just excited to see geraldine come
in here too because as a 60s
episode like i know her from mad men
which is like oh really
yeah she she comes in in one of the
mid-seasons as dawn's secretary and she
becomes like a main supporting or one of
the main ensemble characters so
to see her introduced in this 60s vibe i
was like wait a minute hold on which
show am i watching
pretty sure that's monica rambo i'm
pretty sure that's her
i bet you're correct about that yeah
yeah i'm going with it actually no i
changed my mind you're wrong
even if we get to the next episode and
it's revealed that monica rambo's a
different person
i'm still going to stand by it yeah
definitely nothing problematic about
that
stick to your guns all right never
change your mind even for updated
factual information
all right guys well one division episode
two keep a lookout for a reaction for
next week
what do you guys think leave your
theories down below
any easter i mean we don't really look
uh the only easter egg we
we caught was the close-up on the symbol
of hydra and said struck around
so hydra must be involved in some way
though oh yeah and in this particular
case hydra must be involved
i don't even think about the possibility
of hydra themselves
hey man you cut off one head and a
million more grow back
that's to say guys subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
thank you again aaron for editing this
video
last but not least
adelia chamberlain adelia i know that
you really love loki but i know you're a
big marvel fan and you've been really
looking forward
to one division as well i know you've
been excited about this so i'm glad that
this show has come out for you in 2021
i know how difficult 2020 was for you
so the fact that this show came out so
early on in the year
i hope my only hope is that this series
is able to
make your 2021 off to a little bit of a
better start
in january especially with knowing
some folks who are in your household at
the moment besides that point though
i do want to say as difficult as 2020
was for a lot of us
you're one of the main people who helped
make 2020 a significantly better year
for us you've been rocking our socks for
such a long time
i love the hell out of you sorry i
haven't gotten back to you in a little
bit
i know i got a message in my twitter
waiting to reply to you
i promise i will get back to you soon
just playing a little ketchup at the
moment
but i love you my dear and i hope that
you've been enjoying the series
and i really do sincerely mean it when i
say i'm putting out a lot of positivity
for you
that 2021 could be way more you're here
oh yeah 2020 was gonna kill it kill it
adelia
kill it you are the master but the past
[Laughter]
star war
you